Thank You Lindsay and the entire student
body for that wonderful gift I very much
look forward to opening it someday and
cherishing the foreign memories of this
wonderful first year and I have to say
that it's been such a privilege to be
president of this university and one of
the highlights of my first year is the
enormous opportunity to interact with
student leaders and all of the
undergraduate students so thank you so
much and now especially pleased to
introduce our student speaker who was
selected by a committee of faculty staff
and students Brian Lewis is a master's
degree candidate in engineering in
energy science technology and policy who
in 2013 received his Bachelor of Science
degree in civil and environmental
engineering and engineering and public
policy brian is a young person with a
clear mission he brings his strong
technical training and passion to
advance the important goal of moving our
country forward toward a sustainable
energy future especially in the
expansion of renewable sources of energy
it's my great pleasure to introduce
Brian Lewis
Wow Wow this is uh this is graduation
this is big I think I want to
commemorate this moment first before we
get started with the only way I know how
to commemorate a moment in the 21st
century with a selfie we're gonna take a
selfie really quick I don't know if we
put that in today
what did you see when you first stepped
onto this campus some four years ago
what did you hear what did you feel what
did you think four years ago did you
think that you'll be sitting in that
chair with that cap and that gown ready
to receive the largest and most
expensive piece of paper you've ever
gotten in your life I mean really hasn't
sunk in yet class of 2014 it is finally
time to graduate but more than that it's
time to reflect on the experiences that
we've had and the knowledge that we've
gained along the way it is time to face
our futures and continue on the journey
to find our purpose but before we do
that let me tell you what our experience
has been like here at CMU some of us are
double majors or even triple majors with
two minors 72 units seven clubs
president and an astronaut in our spare
time but it wasn't about scoring points
on our resumes it was about testing the
limits of our own abilities pushing the
boundaries of what we thought possible
and discovering our limitless capacity
for greatness for me my experience here
has really helped to define who I am and
so while you're still awake I want to
share three of these reflections with
you today that's it just three and that
is that in your journey to develop your
passions and to find your purpose to
always remember to know who you are know
where you came from and to know what
matters coming to CMU was a change from
anything I've ever done in my life if
you're like me your first visit here
fills you with mixed feelings of
excitement anxiety curiosity and fear
you walked out onto the cut as classes
led out to see scores of men and women
on their way to the next learning
adventure you listened to the
conversations of people discussing
anything and everything from the
intricacies of string theory to the
latest buggy free roll times and finally
as you admired that walking to the sky
statue your eyes looked to the sky and
you asked yourself where is the Sun and
why is it so damn cloudy but even still
you notice there was something special
something different about this place and
its people you decide to give CMU a try
in our time here we've shared many
valuable experiences experiences like
waiting 20 minutes for a bus only to
have them all show up at the same time
or like getting some friends together
out on the cut for a good old game of
Quidditch it's really fun
or maybe not quite remembering
everything you did that one carnival
night yeah lots of guilty faces out
there the tough programming assignments
tested your ability to reason the long
nights in Pernell tested your patience
and your body the early mornings for
buggy tested your will to endure
whatever your individual experience has
been know that each one of us has done
something to define what tartan pride is
all about one thing for certain is that
over these years CMU has picked you up
broken you put you back together said
sorry and then broken you again but each
breakdown was really simply an
opportunity a chance to pick up our
pieces to remote ourselves a chance to
discover who we are and that's the first
step know who you are know where you
came from
and know what matters I won't lie to you
some of my most troubling times have
come in this very place at one point
night after night I would cry myself to
sleep then wake up the next morning
force a smile just to make it through
the next day I was failing classes my
personal life was a wreck my confidence
was fading I honestly I started
questioning whether I even belong to you
at all it was one thing in then another
and then another
I stood there dejected disheartened and
depressed
I felt naked stripped of all I had come
to love about myself but in the end I
was not alone I had my family and I had
my community I think of my family and
all they've done for me come from the
Detroit area the financial recession in
the auto industry collapse it shook us
hard
I came to CMU as a card-carrying member
of the American middle class and by the
next year we were in bankruptcy I
worried and I worried I asked myself
what if I have to drop out or if I can't
pay for school my dad sat me down and
told me Brian it's okay we are going to
get you through college and they did
make no mistake about it I would not be
standing here I would not be standing
here today we're not for their love and
their sacrifice so wherever you come
from Detroit Pittsburgh China India or
anywhere else in the world know that
your family has sacrificed for you they
put your goals and your aspirations even
ahead of their own they have helped you
succeed even in the face of seemingly
insurmountable odds they love you even
though you don't call them
sorry mom
our families and our culture's are the
foundation for all that we do it remains
true that we cannot know where we are
going without first paying tribute to
where we have been and so in our journey
of purpose we must always remember to
stay true to our values our our families
our our communities we must remember
where we came from and that's the second
step know who you are know where you
came from and know what matters so what
matters to you what matters to me is the
same as what mattered to my granddad two
generations removed from slavery the son
of a sharecropper in North Carolina my
grandfather got his bachelor's and his
master's degree he became he became an
educator and a school superintendent
he was a deacon in the church and he
spent his entire life connecting with
people
education was his passion people were
his passion he was 101 years old when he
died last February and at the funeral in
the church where he and my grandmother's
picture still hangs and trying upon the
wall there was standing room only people
lined outside of the church for a chance
to enter and pay their respects my
grandfather wasn't rich nor was he the
smartest man in the world but he knew
what mattered
my grandfather embodied selflessness his
fulfillment came not only through his
own success but through the successes of
others he teaches us that in the end we
won't be remembered for how many degrees
we receive or how much money we make but
for what we give and for what we share
for how we make people feel that's what
really matters
give of yourself and let your passions
inspire others and then when all is said
and done although your body may wither a
little bit of you lives on within
someone else
class of 2014 we are the next generation
of leaders of innovators and thinkers
what we do will ultimately set the
course of history for years to come but
we must always remember that our purpose
is not manifest within our own successes
and failures but in what we leave behind
a legacy a seed what we've learned here
in our time here at CMU will serve as a
platform for our future success we've
discovered ourselves we've held true to
our values but now we must fulfill our
purpose and so as we leave this place
diploma in hand I challenge each and
every one of you to remain forever
mindful of what truly matters it is your
family your friends your children that
person to your left and that person to
your right yeah those people those who
came before and those who are still yet
to come
always remember that we matter thank you
class of 2014 congratulations